your recent a new job uh congratulations
about that uh you are now in are no
longer in los alamos
uh gsi technology you want to end this
discussion with a little bit of uh
description of work that you're doing
so i really want to finish this for
trade compiler and so
i think i don't know if it's because
most people are these big you know
companies are moving away from fortran
or what it is but it was hard for me to
get funding i did find some i was very
happy about it about
30 of my time um and i'm very grateful
for that
but i really wanted to focus 100 on this
and so i
found this company called gsi technology
it's a hardware company they develop
chips
and they they they're mainly their
business uh is uh selling memory chips
but uh they also recently started uh
developing their own uh uh actually like
a
computational chip competing in memory
and it's much faster than this tpu for
certain tasks and so but it has a very
peculiar their own you know new
architecture and so they wanted to make
it easier for people to program and so
they have a compiler team
and they
uh liked the fortran design and so i uh
decided to join them and so we are now a
compiler developer full-time uh working
on
using the fortran um middle and the back
end
um they don't mind fortran but you know
as we discuss python is the most um kind
of the first language that needs to work
and so we are also writing a python
front end to the same
middle end that alfortune uses and so
i'm now working pretty much on the on
this compiler on this compound
technology full time and so i'm very
excited about it it's um
and also we have
funding for uh students so if any of you
are interested uh listening and if you
are interested in working with us let me
know just contact me uh
uh we have something that you are
interested in working with students do
you mean in the form of internships
internships and you don't even have to
be a student now but yes internships
[Music]
and other opportunities i i believe our
students would love this part of the
conversation
email me
email me all right okay